tout à l'heure donnez-nous une
quatorzième universités on étouffe paris
croule sous le poids des étudiants c'est
vous que la capitale accueille 35 % des
étudiants français moralité des
amphithéâtres surchargés des locaux qui
s'abîme vite et des étudiants qui
abandonnent très tôt trop tôt du fait
des mauvaises conditions de travail et
pour pallier cette difficulté le
gouvernement a décidé de décentraliser
le premier cycle c'est à dire les deux
premières années d'études en a plein en
implantant pardon dans la région
parisienne et dans le nord de la france
des annexes d'université voici le
reportage à melun de lorraine cuisine il
y a quatre mois encore dans cette cour
jouer des élèves de maternelle me lie
accueille cette année deux cent
cinquante étudiants en première année de
droit et d'économie de paris ii assas
la ville a réussi le pari de transformer
cette école en mini universités en
s'inscrivant à sas les étudiants
savaient qu'ils risquaient d'être
affectés dans sept à n'être plus des
deux tiers d'entre eux sont de melun ou
des environs les autres sont moins
chanceux
j'étais contente quand vous avez su vous
étiez affecté à melun oui mais j'ai
demandé mon
non parce que ça m'évitait de monter sur
paris et d'avoir le point de logement
etc
j'habite à savigny sur orge et au
normalement ça n'aurait fait trois
heures de transport par jour
j'ai préféré prendre une chambre à melun
mais les plus mécontents de leurs
affectations sont séduits par les
conditions d'enseignement locaux petit
effectif hanté des dialogues plus facile
avec les enseignants on est loin du
gigantisme et de l'anonymat parisiens
souvent source d' abandon dès le début
de l'année bref une transition douce
avec le lycée oui ici quand on arrive on
est tellement peu que ces paraissent pas
vraiment angoissant quand on se retrouve
dans un amphi milliards au début d'année
droit économie et monstres ou presque
quatre heures à 2000 3000
c'est assez impressionnant a paru fin
2008 à moi moi je connais quelqu'un qui
se mène pas encore son cours alors donc
tu manqueras moitié des coûts j'apprécie
aussi moi en tant que professeur je leur
fais aussi les travaux dirigés
c'est à dire que je les suis
complètement qui n'a pas été compris en
cours je peux leur ai expliqué pendant
l'été des alors qu'à paris les chargés
de td sont très nombreux et sont pas
toujours au courant de l'évolution du
cours du professeur de plus en plus les
universitaires souhaite séparer les deux
premières années d'études des sticks
ultérieure pour mieux encadrer les
étudiants néophytes une solution qui
convient à ceux de melun mais à une
condition être rattachés à une
université mers réputé avoir un diplôme
avec un label connu l'un tout court sans
sans rattachement à la la fac d'assas
certainement pas savoir que le corps
enseignant de melun est exactement le
même corps enseignant qu'à paris deux
étudiants passeront leurs examens sans
doute dans les locaux d'assas mais en ce
qui concerne le niveau d'études et la
sanction des études il n'y a aucune
crainte à avoir
le succès ou l'échec futur de cette
expérience est en fait très important
avec l'objectif de 2 millions
d'étudiants en l'an 2000
ces petites antennes universitaires
devront se multiplier